unos investigadores de mercado
condujeron un estudio comparativo de los
salarios de los gerentes en una tienda
grande de menudeo a nivel nacional los
investigadores obtuvieron datos
salariales y demográficos para una
muestra aleatoria de gerentes los
investigadores calcularon el salario
promedio de los hombres en la muestra y
el salario promedio de las mujeres en la
muestra de los hombres por un lado y de
las mujeres por otro quieren probar si
los hombres gerentes tienen un salario
promedio más alto que el de las mujeres
gerentes supón que todas las condiciones
para la inferencia se satisfacen cuál de
las siguientes opciones es la prueba y
la hipótesis alternativa más apropiada y
puedes ver que están hablando de pruebas
temp variadas o de pruebas de dos
muestras y después hablan de la
hipótesis alternativa así que pausa el
vídeo e intenta resolverlo por tu cuenta
bien primero vamos a tratar de pensar en
la diferencia entre una prueba tema
variada y una prueba tema de dos
muestras como la tenemos aquí en una
prueba de pares adam vamos a construir
una hipótesis alrededor de un parámetro
para la población que a menudo va a ser
la diferencia media de modo que si
tenemos una población por aquí aquí
estamos hablando de la situación de la
prueba de parada y digamos que nos
preguntamos algo común las personas
corren más rápido cuando usan shorts o
cuando usan pantalones entonces para
cada miembro de la población puedes ver
que si tuvieras información perfecta
sabrías qué tan rápido correrían con
pantalones y qué tan rápido correrían
con shorts después
podrías calcular la diferencia y al
utilizar toda la población podrías
obtener esa diferencia media la
diferencia media de pantalones menos
shorts y por supuesto para poder estimar
eso o para realizar una
problema de hipótesis alrededor de esto
vamos a tomar una muestra y luego de
esta muestra vamos a calcular la media
muestral de la diferencia en este caso
de bueno de pantalones de los shorts y
con esto puedes construir una hipótesis
nula de modo que no sea esta media de
aquí no sea igual a cero y dirías sí
supongo que la hipótesis nula es
verdadera es decir que entra el día se
cumple que la media de los pantalones
menos los shorts es igual a cero cuál es
la probabilidad de que haya obtenido
este resultado que está por debajo del
nivel de significancia y si esa
probabilidad es menor que es el nivel de
significancia entonces rechazaría esta
hipótesis nula y sugeriría la hipótesis
alternativa que podría ser que esta
media es mayor que cero
por otro lado en una prueba de de dos
muestras vamos a tener dos poblaciones
distintas no se está y está tal vez esta
sea la población de hombres y tal vez
esta sea la de mujeres y quieres
comparar la media entre estas dos no sé
digamos el salario promedio así que
tienes el salario promedio para los
hombres y el salario promedio para las
mujeres y lo que estás tratando de hacer
con una prueba de hipótesis es obtener
conclusiones acerca de la diferencia
media de estos dos parámetros así que
vemos el salario promedio de los hombres
no sea como ocurre pensarlo así el
salario promedio de los hombres menos el
salario promedio de las mujeres en
nuestra hipótesis lula es que no hay
diferencia entre estas dos si nos
fijamos en la hipótesis nula vamos a
observar
qué esta diferencia tiene que ser igual
a cero es decir no cambia y ahora si los
investigadores quieren probar si los
gerentes que son hombres tienen un
salario diferente entonces nuestra
hipótesis alternativa se va a ver algo
como esto como que la media de los
hombres menos la media de las mujeres
esto no es igual a cero esto es nuestra
hipótesis alternativa pero no están
probando si las medias son diferentes si
leemos por aquí dicen ellos quieren
probar si los hombres gerentes tienen un
salario promedio más alto que de las
mujeres gerentes por lo tanto vamos a
borrar este símbolo de que no es igual y
en lugar de él vamos a poner el símbolo
de mayor que bueno qué opciones están
claramente estamos en la situación de
una prueba de 2
muestras estamos aquí y queremos usar el
signo mayor que que está justo aquí así
que seleccionaremos la opción c esa es
la respuesta y hemos terminado nos vemos
en el siguiente vídeo